hey are you doing
Hey Allah Allah Allah Allah
starts working within five minutes to
relieve bigotry and intolerance all your
doctor if you're Islamic phobia worsens
or you have a loser nations that
discrimination isn't real
so we are trying to like to face the
hate with love and ignorance with
knowledge
side effects include fondness
Brotherhood acceptance loss of bigotry
increase in rationality and possible
denouncement of superiority
something where it's real it's not just
something that we fear is something that
Muslims are suffering from every single
day
I didn't realize I had a problem but
admitting is the first step